[Musique]
un faux intox est avec vous Antoine
fenaud bonjour bonjour Raphaël et au
menu aujourd'hui l'Ukraine avec une
vidéo virale censé montrer à la
destruction d'un convoi de l'OTAN
absolument une vidéo basée notamment sur
ce poste Facebook vous allez le voir il
a largement circulé sur Facebook
notamment et vous le voyez il est
meilleur du groupe des Patriotes du Mali
et il relaie ici ce que vous voyez une
vidéo que je vais vous montrer un petit
peu plus tard avec ce titre Ukraine un
convoi des conseillers militaires de
l'Otan détruit par l'armée russe on
revoit un peu cette tonalité qui est
désormais antioxydantal un très présente
au Mali depuis l'arrivée au pouvoir de
la jinte plus de quasiment 5000
commentaires près de plus de 8000
partages et la vidéo en elle-même donc
là voici vous allez le voir qu'est-ce
que l'essent c'est montrer c'est une
vidéo d'assez mauvaise qualité il faut
bien le dire qu'est-ce qu'on y voit on y
voit des véhicules militaires ou la
percevez juste ici qui sont en train de
circuler sur une route et ces villes ces
véhicules militaires visiblement des
temps qui vont être la cible de bombarde
de tir de missiles je vois accélérer un
petit peu la vidéo vous allez voir on va
y arriver voilà donc vous voyez un
convoi militaire qui est donc ciblé par
des bombards bombardements donc il faut
dire pour le petit peu de contexte
notamment que se pose lui fait référence
à l'aide de l'OTAN à l'armée ukrainienne
notamment on en parlait sur France 24
souvenez vous cette notamment cette
récente livraison de matériel solaire
donc à l'Ukraine voilà pour le contexte
Raphaël alors d'où vient cette vidéo
Antoine et bien contrairement à ce qu'on
fait d'habitude vous en avez désormais
l'habitude avec moi Raphaël la recherche
d'image inversée c'est notre petite
marotte ici un fond intox et bien elle
ne fonctionne pas pour une simple et
bonne raison c'est que la vidéo elle est
de trop mauvaise qualité alors ce qu'on
a fait c'est qu'on s'est dit à un fond à
toi que je voulais montrer la vidéo les
déplacements de caméra ont l'air très
fluide la vidéo est vraiment de mauvaise
qualité elle nous a interrogé sur son
côté presque un peu trop parfait donc on
s'est dit il est possible que ce soit
une vidéo
issue
jeux vidéo notamment un jeu vidéo qu'on
a beaucoup vu tourner dans d'autres
scènes d'infox c'est un jeu vidéo qui
s'appelle ArmA 3 et effectivement quand
on prend quand on prend notre notre
vidéo et comptable ArmA 3 tank distri
sur Facebook sur Youtube pardon et bien
on tombe sur cette chaîne que vous
apercevez ici cet homme il s'appelle
Millman et il partage des vidéos de
justement extraites de ce jeu vidéo il
met en scène des simulations c'est un
jeu très précis on va y revenir un petit
peu plus tard vous voyez avec des vidéos
de de matériel antérien de bombardements
et militaire notamment et on y retrouve
également cette vidéo là elle vous
semble elle vous elle va vous attirer un
peu le regard parce que c'est exactement
la même vidéo que je vous ai montré un
petit peu avant sauf que les deux bien
meilleurs qualité naturellement c'était
intentionnel et là qu'est-ce qu'on y
voit donc cette vidéo elle date du 20
juillet dernier et donc c'est un extrait
tout simplement de ce jeu vidéo qui
s'appelle donc arma III et là on y voit
donc et bien le joueur met en scène donc
cette destruction de de blindés par des
pièces anti tank donc vous l'avez
compris Raphaël ce n'est pas la première
fois que les images de ce jeu sont
utilisées Antoine oui absolument je vous
le disais justement c'est ça qui est
intéressant c'est que ce jeu ArmA 3
justement je vous ai choisi un petit peu
la page d'accueil voilà ça ressemble à
ça qu'on peut le voir le télécharger
assez facilement sur Internet et nous
ici info intox on a vu plusieurs fois
des des infos qui sont reprenant des
images de ce jeu c'était notamment le
cas déjà à propos de l'Ukraine récemment
notamment avec ce poste Facebook que
vous voyez juste ici avec là encore une
vidéo d'image de caméras de vision
nocturne issue lui-même de jeu avec
cette infox qui circulait qui avait à
l'époque cumulé près de 90 000 vues et
là encore l'OTAN était ciblé qui aurait
donc envoyé des hélicoptères et des
avions de chasse pour aider directement
l'Ukraine face aux Russes et c'était
également le cas dans une autre infox
qui elle ciblesse cette fois-ci la les
cures des notamment la Turquie avec
notamment cette vidéo que vous voyez
aussi ces images de drones vu de prise
de prise prise aérienne de drone de nuit
avec là encore soi-disant c'était censé
montrer la le massacre de Kurdes
pardonnez-moi la massacre de cure par
l'armée turque au Kurdistan donc voilà
vous voyez c'est là encore ces images de
jeux qui ont été utilisés à tel point
d'ailleurs elles ont tellement été
utilisées que les créateurs eux-mêmes ne
se jeux vidéo de ArmA 3 ont dû s'en
expliquer et dans un tweet que vous
voyez ici donc c'est le second les
créateurs eux-mêmes de la plateforme qui
le disent il dit nous avons observé
quelques nous avons observé à plusieurs
reprises ça c'était au début de la
guerre vous le voyez c'est ce tweet il y
a du 25 février 2022 donc juste après
notre début de la guerre en Ukraine nous
avons vu plusieurs vidéos
de notre jeu et bien refaire surface
pour pour soi-disant dépeindre la que la
réalité en
Ukraine donc vous le voyez vous l'avez
compris donc en résumé une vidéo d'un
jeu vidéo et pas du tout un convoi de
l'OTAN qui se fait bombarder vous l'avez
compris merci Antoine